el anuncio de las fuerzas ucranianas de
comenzar esa contraofensiva para retomar
la provincia de gerzón especialmente la
capital gerson que fue la primera gran
capital de provincia que fue tomada por
el control de las fuerzas rusas a
comienzos de marzo está teniendo actos
ofensivos bastante importantes desde
ambos lados ayer en la noche de ayer las
tropas ucranianas aseguraban que habían
atacado 18 veces el puente antonio vsc y
que es el puente más importante que
comunica la isla de crimea con esta
provincia de gerzón y es a través de
este puente que viene todos los
refuerzos logísticos de los rusos para
apoyar a su ejército en la defensa de
esta provincia y al mismo tiempo las
fuerzas de moscú aseguraban haber
atacado en varias ocasiones la ciudad de
nikolai de esa ciudad cercana a gerson y
que es un puente entre la ciudad de
gerzón y la ciudad dio de esa que sería
el gran objetivo sobre el mar negro que
ha sido permanentemente atacada desde el
comienzo de la guerra y habrían atacado
un puerto o un centro comercial y varios
edificios donde las autoridades rusas
habrían estarían muchísimos militares
sin embargo las autoridades ucranianas
no confirman estas pérdidas pero lo que
sí hemos sabido desde la ciudad de
mykolaiv es que el ataque de anoche fue
bastante intenso